it is a city built on its maritime
fortune home to more than 260 thousand
but a mile from the luxury yachts
plymouth's cost of living crisis
is biting hard on the tuesday night i'm
in the red i'm in my overdraft
every every week every week
mum of three lara works full-time
but now
that isn't enough
every week i'm
about 80 pound in the red and then i'll
get paid wednesday
and i thank god i'll get paid every
wednesday but then by let's say the
thursday friday with bill's coming out
and i've got to buy food and
you know this has got to be paid
i'm very lucky to have any of my wages
left that should be enough her
electricity and gas bill has gone up
from 71 to
224 pounds a month i'll be honest with
you i've cancelled the direct debit and
it frightens me because of things well
they're going to send me a letter and
say well you've got to pay it
you know you're constantly worrying
with things so tight there's no budget
for treats
i just feel like a rubbish terrible i
feel like i'm failing as a mum to be
fair and i could cry
this part of plymouth is in the top 1 of
most deprived areas in the whole of
england it was on a knife edge long
before anyone had ever heard of the
costs of living crisis
at the community cafe round the corner
from lara's flat the cost of food fuel
and bills is on everyone's mind
there's not enough money for the month
at all
we get about three weeks in and we've
got nothing so the last
literally nothing
wages in plymouth are below the national
average but it's not just those working
being hit plymouth's pensioners are
finding that this isn't the retirement
they'd hoped for
friends david selick and david perkins
have lived in plymouth all their lives
they say the money they get from the
state
isn't keeping up with the cost of living
gas and electric paying 150 pounds a
month i only get just almost 600 pounds
a month and
that's the third of it
gone just like that and then you got
food on top and then you got other bills
it's getting to be a struggle it's
getting bad it's hitting me hard and
it's frightening me as a person being
disabled as well
the government's latest package of
support will help the likes of david and
lara but as the financial squeeze gets
worse
no one really knows how tight it's going
to get
dan white is sky news in plymouth